would you ever dump someone via text  message no be very nervous to play the  let detector thing this will make or  break our friendships I'd lie all the  necessity so that's why I'm nervous  today's cuz he I would say knows the  most about me I can tell when Sabrina is  lying because I also know how she is  when she's acting and she lies the same  way that she had do I really yeah I'm  ready to play the light would you ever  look at adult content on your phone you  think you're the best-looking person in  this room yes don't do that if you saw  an accident on the side of the road  would you stop and help yes would you  ever make out on the first day no would  you ever eat my boogers for money  [Music]  you can't corrupt this mataji everything  good about him was reaffirmed today yeah  I was shocked he wouldn't eat my boobs  for $1,000  [Music]